the game within a game secrets of a
college football signal stealer and
there's a lot of other good NFL tidbits
right here in this piece that you can
get on the athletic with Bruce Feldman
here in person on the Rich Eisen show
good to see you Bruce good to see you
what inspired you to write this piece uh
I was having a meal with a coach I know
and we started talking about this mutual
friend we had and I had no idea this guy
had another skill that he was this
amazing signal stealer
and it started to go down that that
college or in a film this guy has mostly
worked in college he did work in the NFL
briefly okay for a little bit a couple
years but the more we talked about it I
was like well I don't know if this guy's
ever gonna want to even anonymously talk
about what he does and how he does it
I was like why would you want to do that
but then when I approached this person
he was like yeah I'll talk to you and we
had I don't know three long our
conversations at a time and started to
go down that rabbit hole and then the
further I got the more I was like okay
how widespread is this and so I started
calling other coaches and then I want to
see the comparison between that and the
NFL and talk to guys who worked in both
and then it's just fascinating the more
you you know you talked to another
couple guys and go you need to talk to
this guy he's awesome at it like he's
the best I've ever worked and he find
out how that guy did it and talked to
guys in the NFL and it was so
fascinating to me on so many different
levels because it's been going on for so
long
and some of the stuff you're like okay
that's kind of elementary I could like
how could you not figure that out kind
of thing but it happened so fast and in
college the players can't retain that
much they don't it's like this is their
only job where all the time so some of
the signals can be pretty basic but then
there's a lot of stuff you know when you
see in college you have like three
different signalers and this my signal
stealer guy explained to me goes it's
actually not as hard as you think it
would be why not he goes you were
studying body language and he goes these
guys are not actors they're football
players they're trying to play football
so maybe they're turning away when one
guy stops well you know that's the guy
you know or you know the guy who's who's
live is the one who's like kind of his
body language ends up coming out a
little further there's just a lot like a
stepped feller a step before the other
two guys yeah there's just lots of
little
things that we're studying what about
these signs of like now there you know
Chip Kelly who's here in UCLA kind of
started the holding up the faces like
Scott Van Pelt's faces up there and then
there's all sorts of you know yeah if
there's an actresses is that all I men
now they're holding up sheets there's
sheets being the sheets were trying to
block people so Arizona State when Todd
grandmas head coach had a pretty bad
reputation or a pretty elaborate
reputation for for being very aggressive
as signal stealers so the sheets were
trying to block people just like when
you'd see you know the NFL coach holding
a Denny's menu in front of them to try
to try to do that I had one guy tell me
he said you know I was charting plays
and they I didn't know it but one of my
friends who I knew really well later in
the season goes you know we're watching
you he's like yeah you guys know you can
we can tell from what you're doing if
it's gonna be a run or past the run
plays are a lot shorter the past plays
are a lot longer and he's like yeah that
makes sense
so it's now I'm like scribbling and
dummy stuff I mentioned that to another
guy I know from the NFL side and he said
what we would do is we would have with
like the third string quarterback who's
supposed to be charting plays he would
tell it to a guy who's probably on the
practice squad in you know in not in
uniform he's writing something down I'm
in front of him and they have somebody
standing behind him to kind of shield so
it's like just when you think the
coaches could could not be more paranoid
you find out there's a reason why
they're paranoid you know I had one one
a head coach tell me when he was an
assistant somewhere he said we want a
conference championship because the day
before the game one of our assistants
happened to be watching the local news
and they saw like a local reporter doing
a stand-up and they watched you know
like in the background they could see
the offense running a short yardage play
and kind of going through their walk
through he's like I bet you this is what
they're gonna run on you know third and
inches and it's exactly what they ran
and you could see like I went back and
watch the watch the actual play this is
from you know five years ago or so and
you can see you can see them blow it up
Bruce Feldman here on the Rich Eisen
show and reading your piece
it's amazing uh when the news came out a
few weeks ago I had a reaction I'm
thinking many fans we're listening
watching the show I had a same reaction
to the news that five fewer headset
wearing people would be allowed to wear
headsets on college football sidelines
and booths this fall and I read that out
of mine why are these coaches so upset
about it like what what what is the big
deal and I thought what could be a big
deal what couldn't be a big deal and
then I read your piece and I see like
sign ceiling may have something to do
with the reason why coaches are so upset
that be so five fewer people who might
be assigned to see that stealing signs
with headsets to immediately communicate
it to somebody who can actually affect
change on the field yeah that's what
they're upset about that's that is a big
part of it from what I'm told so now the
rule is there are only 20 headsets which
sounds like a lot but you have ten
assistants a head coach four players
that's that's 15 for graduate assistants
now you have one headset for some
off-field omnibus one headset so who's
gonna get that headset well one of the
best signal sewers from what I've
understood when I asked him about this
he goes well what what the issue is
gonna be is you can't do it really from
field level he goes what are you gonna
stand next to the defensive coordinator
he's like you can't it's hard to write
stuff down it's not like you're sitting
on a table where you have better luck
Euler can't really do it from field
level you're also kind of affected by
80,000 people in the crowd where you can
you know it's just harder to focus in on
and so after here having that
conversation was funny I looked back and
saw who the head coach who seemed to be
the most outspoken and aggrieved by this
and it was a head coach whose team I you
know heard a bunch really is very
proactive in signal stealing and trying
to do that with a bloated staff so is
there any other reason why someone would
be upset of five commissioners there
could be other reason but if it's
definitely gonna put crimp the reason
why that is is that the reason why this
rule was put into place to drive back
that's the only reason but like there
was talk about adding more technology to
the game because certain technology
companies would like like iPads in in
the coach's box and this one guy who is
like I honestly made a living at signal
stealing but that was a big part of his
MO he's known by guys on his staff as
the guy at different places and he said
if you have that he goes coaches are
gonna get tempted they're gonna start
they're gonna start filming guys do
signaling that's just how human nature
these are ultra competitive individuals
and we can't have that shooting people
giving signals where have I heard that
before Chris you want to help me with
that one
people who train like a camera
specifically trained on people signaling
in place I've been telling you guys ring
a bell if you're not cheating you're not
trying since about 2005 thanks for
finally getting on board I want to hit
that and the NFL stuff that you've
recovered you you pegged one team in
particular that has had a reputation for
it from back in the day they're the best
and we're maybe they're the worst how
many well I mean and it's still
sensitive I bet and I want to hit that a
little bit in 60 seconds and then the
the general sense of what the community
of football coaches feels about this
endeavor Bruce Feldman it's a
fascinating piece in the athletic the
game within a game secrets of a college
football signal stealer that's next in
60 seconds
[Music]
all right I'm in my Mexican kit Delta
foe and his Japanese kit
we lost our World Cup bet with the clean
faced Chris Brockman who is Argentine
team got a garbage goal late against
anything advance that got him through in
our silly competition that is why he
dressed like Landon Donovan in a bank ad
I've got my friend Bruce Feldman to my
right great piece the game within a game
secrets of a college football signal
stealer I mean inside stuff to say the
least
including the fact when you talk about
the NFL you mentioned the Indianapolis
Colts as a team with a reputation during
the dungey peyton manning era of stunts
of sign stealing and you even got a
coach pegged named in this piece who was
particularly good at it
correct yeah legendary Howard Mudd the
longtime of a lion coach so in his I
think a dozen years or so mm with the
Colts fewer sacks in the NFL over that
that stretch obviously they threw it a
lot with Peyton Peyton but talking to so
I talked to somebody who was on the
Colts then that's just raved about how
good Howard mud f was that a former
Colts player is how you refer to this
individual throughout the piece not only
was he great at it here's the thing
Howard mud yeah was it was not an urban
legend that everybody knew about so it's
like when you go into this game we're
not talking college kids were some of
it's really elementary and hey this
means the power or this means the power
it's like they were doing stuff would be
very subtle and different things ook we
got it we got to be extra careful cuz
cuz Howard mud isn't gonna be on to us
and then it was the way to you know as
this this person with the Colts
explained to me wasn't just that Howard
mud would eventually crack the code he
would be able to communicate it back so
they would have this chain of command to
get to Peyton Manning to know okay
is there pressure coming is it not and
Peyton was so smart and is so smart that
he was able to attacked figure out what
was gonna come from there so it was like
two parts of the process and obviously
you know as this person said it that's
where the magic was and I will not I
will not ask you to out your player
obviously you wouldn't but if you don't
mind me asking how concerned was this
lair communicating this to you Bruce
Feldman this player probably would
prefer is like thinking there's a
sensitivity to this I'm straight there
is you know this day in 2018 yeah and
and what he said to me conveyed to me
and I think this was genuine not just
him saying well this is the reason why I
want to cover my tracks kind of thing
was that you don't want it to take away
from any part of Peyton Manning's legacy
because in a lot of ways this up this
kind of underscores how brilliant he was
because he was able to get that part of
the information and other people can go
well you're getting the answers to the
test but he really wasn't getting the
answers to the test but he was getting
information and I was like okay how are
we going to manage it and that's not to
say that they're the only ones doing it
from but from everything I had heard
they were the best doing it so I asked
my Patriot friend who loves to say if
you ain't cheating you ain't trying
you're fine with that you found with
that because if you're gonna be able to
glean this information and other teams
don't protect that information this is
before the headset it was allowed to put
in your piece was allowed to be put on a
defensive player which is removed a lot
of this from the game so you found with
them it's on you to protect the
information is that the general sense
you get from industry folks who spoke to
you about that it is I think what what
kind of separated these guys with the
Colts is like colleges don't radically
change signals they're dealing with
college kids a lot of times these
college kids just they're trying they're
trying to remember where they're
supposed to line up on a given play much
less all this other stuff that's
happened on the fly with the NFL its
next level and as you said when the
earpiece went in for the quarterback and
for the Mike linebacker that cut down on
some of this stuff because in college do
you guys see a lot of no huddle they
don't have the earpiece right there's a
lot of you know and you have less with
college you have less you know I don't
say less intelligence but you just have
less experience savvy goddess's well I
mean look the number three overall pick
in the draft
Sam darn 'old every single time he went
to the line he would they would hurry up
they wouldn't huddle but he would stop
after lined up and just stare at the
side with me that's the thing that's
serious
the sideline I mean and he's not the
only one no that's most of them that's
many of them and I think what you would
see like I had a an offensive
coordinator who's relatively young tell
me he was my defensive coordinator in
psychology I thought he goes I just want
to know if it's runner past and he's
like it doesn't work that way anymore
because whether it's our POS we have all
these and this coach said you know I
call runs like 75% of the time but it
will turn into run Pass you know 5050
because that's what the defense is kind
of reacting to so we're gonna counter
punch to it and I think when you talk
about the level on the NFL side this is
a part that you know we didn't have room
for this part in the story
I talked to a coach who they would face
the Patriots quite a bit and he said you
might get Tom Brady once but he is going
to burn you the next you know next time
what do you mean by get Tom bruh the
example they had was they thought they
knew by the stagger of his feet in the
red zone which way a handoff might go
they blew it up from what he said once
the next time was like a walk in
touchdown so that break so you're by
that you mean this they did understand a
Brady tell once but Brady and whoever
else Belichick or what have you picked
up on the fact that they found that tel
and used it against the exact time and
NFL teams and I've heard this with I've
heard this about Sean Payton and and
Drew Brees as well these guys self
scouts so much they are able to take
advantage of when they think that you're
on to them with something and they will
burn it burn you it with it whereas in
college you don't see that as much
because they just they're just
scrambling to deal with with a hundred
kids and you think you know we sit here
and say well how much action is in a
football game technical attend twelve
actual real life minutes because I bet
once the play is over the plot the play
clock just rolls 30 40 seconds this is
all happening within that 30 40 seconds
in between plays one of the guys is
telling me and this is an NFL guy who
used to be in college and he said you
would be shocked at how much stuff you
can get with off a TV copy he goes bone
use the audio quality now is so good now
it's not oh you know there's different
games different you know
two cameras for her broadcast like in
the NFL obviously but he said you could
hear stuff if I'm a defensive lineman he
goes these guys go home with their iPads
now this is all they're doing they're
not this all they're doing but this is a
big you know this is their their their
careers they can study cadence and the
sound and pick up on stuff and he said
they will know you better than you know
yourself and and I know I know college
teams swamped tape right yeah that's the
at least that's the gentlemen's
agreement that you give us tape on you
we we get tape from you that's another
layer of this because now there's been
and this one particular signal sure said
my head coach was really ticked off
because you can't tell sometimes they
cut out where the motions are like you
just see it like okay they're gonna snap
the ball well that's not right but
instead they're because the people who
are taught to who their their film guys
or say hey make sure you do not cut to
any stuff where they can see the
signaling coming in because then you're
given away our stuff and so it is again
paranoid because they are Wow like they
have a reason to be paranoid because
there's so many examples I think of this
as a reporter where you're just like man
they're really cutting down on access
but you get why because little details
get out and those little details can be
huge difference so last one for you here
Bruce Feldman based on everyone you
spoke to and your knowledge of the game
as long as you've been covering it last
I checked there is a poop ton of money
in college football if it was decided
that they were going to spend the
dollars and cents to get two helmets
like the NFL one for the quarterback one
for your designated linebacker and every
team in major college football now must
play football with the helmets where you
can directly talk to the quarterback and
directly talk to the Mike linebacker
would college football coaches go for
that or they just are so used to and
like this system of stealing that the
system of sealing the culture is so
ingrained that they'd say forget it we
don't want those headsets to remove it I
think some would some
wouldn't because remember a lot of teams
don't huddle in college so you still
let's say you know as my understanding
of it you know it's a one-way it was a
one-way communication it's from the head
coach to to the quarterback well there's
still got to be the quarterback
signalling out to the receivers you know
so or signaling out to the rest of the
offense because unless they're gonna
decide to be a huddle team and so much
has changed because of the up-tempo you
know we talked about Chip Kelly a minute
ago it's just like that stuff has issued
an assured in a new era where it has
changed everything and so you know you
signal Steelers the thing that Don
scares them the most is like if first
play of a drive or right coming out of a
quarter change because you have a you
know a glob of 28 guys you don't know
whose personnel you don't know who's
gonna go on the field you know they can
communicate it differently because they
have everybody there so one time we can
say okay we're gonna do exactly this
because it's not like you know they can
they can control the message then once
they're out in the field if they're if
they're not in a huddle it's like it's
all bets are off great chat man and I
really appreciate you coming in to talk
about it cuz so many folks in your
profession write an article and then
don't want to talk about it I'm show
like this because they're concerned that
folks might not read everything or not
might not seek it out but you just I can
tell everybody you've scratched the
surface of about 15 to 20 percent of the
material that's in your piece it's so
great it's so deep and I appreciate you
coming on to talk about it out on the
athletic again it is all about sign
stealing in in professional and mostly
college football which is right around
the corner here the day before July 4th
Labor Day is just around the corner man
can't wait can't wait look forward to
chatting with you later on this month
and certainly August to get ready for
that season Media Days in a week is it
really which one's all of the big 12
starts first big 12 and sec a week from
Monday
oh so Nick Saban with his do you notice
the tea taps the podium a lot yeah you
can say his body tells where he's a
little what's his body tell what if we
cut if we could there's a rocking and a
swaying from side to side there's the
his cadence his I uses that word I does
you guys
uses you guys a lot and he has about six
of them if you watch him in that hour
when he speaks to the SEC group yeah he
will he will pick up a bunch of them
depending on his mood so which when what
his mood is what when you know he's in a
bad mood I think it was way side to side
mean I'm disappointed in you guys don't
don't go any further
stealing signs even at the podium that's
the way we go at Bruce Feldman cfb on
Twitter we'll chat again soon the Rich
Eisen show weekdays at noon eastern on
audience